bello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuto che
sono video stanno fa vj sono a los
angeles e con l'om diavolo è fini
lo piccolo l'uomo tamarro eccolo là e
sabrina che si è infilata dentro un
negozio che vabbè comunque poi dopo
vedrete nel video e siamo los angeles
perché siamo stati invitati da disney
per essere catapultati nel nuovo mondo
di wright spaccatutto che sarebbe la
spacca internet che sarebbe sequel di
lance manca tutto però ragazzi non posso
ancora dirvi niente
riprenderò questa cosa più avanti però
mentre eravamo qui a los angeles ea fare
determinate cose che poi vedrete
siamo passati anche a disneyland quindi
vi lasciarlo ai ragazzi enjoy
ringrazio sabrina per aver fatto questa
intro che è seduta di fianco a me ci
hanno siamo nei sedili quelli prima
sassi quelli dei ricchi perché ci hanno
preso questi pochi ricchi ma un po meno
perché data ci sono quelli ancora
migliori poi c'è il pilota aveva detto
stiamo andando alla gente c'è il piumone
c'è anche il timone per piacere ci hanno
portato l'acqua perché quando cioè i
posti in prima classe sanno quando ai 7
passeremo tutto il viaggio così allora
ragazzi descrivo la prima classe come ce
lo schermo che esce c'è il tavolino ma
ti portano il menu nel menu c'e tutte le
robe che puoi ordinare le ordini subito
face la bocchetta da qua te la regalano
alla pochette che ti regalano per il
avanti i denti e più [ __ ] di quella che
mi portò in vacanza c'è sabrina
[Musica]
ma allora mi è stato questo viaggio la
skoda cristiano aver comunque chi è che
guida in tutto questo visto che siamo
tutti il rientro si guidano la sola le
macchine in america non lo sapevi
no adesso vediamo adesso che parte in
parte ci sono bar e l'acqua gratis ma
bottiglione gigantesco
[Musica]
gianpi
come in ogni blog come dicono spetto voi
sapete che io in porta e faccio le
opinioni della stampa da oggi siamo in
un il suo hotel sia 30 buon segno se mi
succede che a volte non si apre gli
occhi quella la legge su la cameretta
quella bella a max che camera c'è una
eccola questa porta qui una forza che
collega ad un'altra camera che è
blindata però non cosa che mi ha sempre
in chiesa fu un sacco comunque e notte
mi dispiace solo per questo motivo però
la vista vacca vacca che vista in giro
che veramente figo c'è domani mattina
magari quando mi sveglio lo faccio un po
meglio so cosa ci vediamo domani che si
vedrà un po meglio sorriso miss bella li
sta facendo colazione
notiamo cosa prende lorenzo preparazione
va bene
siamo davanti alla come se il caffè
castello che il castello in castello il
castello di disney
l'ace la statua di walt disney no e
celani 1 un mito quello sicuramente e
c'è della gente che sta facendo la fila
sta qua c'è un sacco di gente in fila
per farla foto con la statua di walt
disney
cioè io la prossima volta che vado a
fare un raduno non troverete me gli
snack che le ragioni di smetto per gli
parli per un annetto method è stato e mi
è addirittura per un anno mammamia anno
si è
metto le mie la mia statua e voi fate la
foto con la star lo fate la cosa è fatta
la foto che questo è il castello di
casoli il castello di disney ragazzi
guarda dietro le quinte vi porto in un
posto voi non lo sapete
in realtà ragazzi quelli che abbiano lì
non sta non sa volare e lì e sta
implorando la gente datemi una mano
perché non so come scendere solo che
tutti gli fanno le foto perché pensano
che sappiamo in realtà non lo sa fare ed
è lì da sei anni siamo a situazioni di
pirati dei caraibi
sto male in ospedale dove andare ragazzi
se pirati dei caraibi dobbiamo andare a
più da pirati dei caraibi tutta la vita
c'è johnny depp che fa ma la statua di
johnny depp comunque johnny depp ha
parcheggiato lì è poi entrato qua dentro
a fare
fall meeting rim sta facendo così col
telefono per 600 volte mi verrà la
nausea
andiamo dai suoi portar lorenzo non ho
ben capito io oggi non è che volevo
bagnarvi però mi hanno costretto sia
sabrina che sta registrando davanti io
sono dio in testa prima così gli schizzi
se ne prende lei la prima però da
paraurti legge c'è da paraschizzi 5
una donna
hai già preso salto
no
ma la caccia telefonino
ciao coniglio
il ristretto zio jala
arrivato giustizia
siamo in questa situazione sono lavato
raga non avete visto tavole avanti
vedo la luce o madonna ma ci sono
passati ci siamo bagnati solo quando non
si è visto bene così ci siamo ribellati
è mancata la giusta
ragazzi siamo impegnati sto male allora
vedo che nella trazione ci siamo
divertiti tantissimo sacri ma
soprattutto io io ho nella sicurezza
veramente contento vabbè
[Musica]
mickey mouse prezzo sabrina ciao cosa
mangi rimanga dov'è ei cowboys dal 26 st
roba se la mangia un bikini
[Musica]
gigantesco
ok se l'abbiamo ragazzi abbiamo i nostri
campioni non ti appartiene
4 3 2 1 seguiamo lin crediamo che lo
fanno percorso steiger è il tuo ma io
già aperti come faccio ora senza di loro
eccoli là e ora li vediamo l'aspettate 3
2 1 poi ho sbagliato ho sbagliato eccoli
ragazzi chiude la giornata a disneyland
veramente figo ora siamo nella hall
dell'hotel di disney cioè questa è la
hall dell'hotel di disneyland cioè non
siamo in realtà ospiti però io girovago
nelle hall degli hotel
lo faccio per ufficio è una figata e
veramente una figata però va beh vi
saluto spero che vi sia piaciuto mi
piace saltare anche da sabrina e lorenzo
se hai ciao ciao
niente lasciato momenti mi piace non
iscrivetevi ai loro canali nostro
scherzando lui non c'era il canale
troppo tamarro per averlo lei ce l'ha
però con quei pantaloni non so se
sull'america prova beh io mando un
bacino
[Musica]